hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the match magnus carlsen versus
alireza first john and now magnus has
the white pieces and he will try to
retaliate against alireza who won a
brilliant game uh in their in their
first clash uh let's dive straight into
it and we do have some insight
as to why magnus was smiling the entire
game as he did continue smiling the
entire second game uh they said that he
was um at the beach with the other chess
players and that they were sort of uh
playing chess now they were probably
also maybe you know having some fun
maybe there was dancing maybe maybe they
uh you know
had a few drinks
who knows what happened at that beach
but yeah i'm sure it was a very well
spent today so let's dive straight into
it magnus has the white pieces and he
opens with c4 so when you want to strike
back you go for the english knight to f6
we have knight to f3 and now pawn to e6
the argent defense is on the board
knight to c3 and the d5 vial it is a c
captures e captures and now pawn to d4
so uh transposing into the exchange
variation of the queen's gambit decline
nothing new here c6 and now bishop g5
being the most popular magnus chooses
queen to c2 instead we have g6 by
alireza now comes bishop to g5 and now
bishop to e7 abandoning the planet of
bishop to g7 e3 by magnus and the bishop
to f5 so nicely developing gaining a
tempo on the queen here but magnus only
now develops the bishop so he didn't
have to waste any tempe bishop captures
queen captures and knight beat to d7 so
nicely developing pieces
and magnus says you are not castling
king sided this game but alerza says i
most certainly am he chases away the
bishop bishop back to f4 and now knight
to f8 re-maneuvering the knight over to
e6
to further harass carlson's bishop and
now there is a game where ponte h3 was
played but here magnus chooses pawn to
h4 and it is now as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game
so uh how do you continue playing this
you do not want to see h5 on the board
so while it is a place h5 himself and
now knight the g5 now this is a very
nasty looking knight and maybe you even
want to get rid of it but if you get rid
of the bishop captures then you can even
play h captures on g5 and this really uh
you know puts the question what is black
to do you're definitely not castling
king's side and with the light square
bishop controlling this diagonal you are
not castling queenside so instead
alireza prepares the castle he plays
queen to d7 we have ponta f3 now chasing
away the knight and now knight to h6 and
here uh alireza does go for the bold
queen side castle but uh only
after a few moves first magnus castles
queen side now we have f6 chasing away
the knight knight to h3 and now knight
to f7 re-maneuvering the knight over to
d6
and magnus strikes in the center with e4
and now uh
it's a question what do you do here you
could go for something like knight to d8
with the idea of bringing the knight
over to e6 to attack the bishop and if
white captures you can always recapture
you do you have control over the d5
square but alireza played the d captures
on e4 magnus played queen captures an e4
and now alireza does castle queen side
and this is a very very dangerous play
with the
uh with carlsen's dark square bishop
controlling this diagonal uh there is uh
there's a problem in the position so
feel free to unleash your inner morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on deciding to open
up the position and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to d5 so congrat congratulations if you
spotted this now uh the point is when uh
deciding on a move like this imagine
okay look at those squares imagine this
knight on a7 that's a beautiful uh
beautiful checkmate so how can we make
this happen well we play d5 now if c
captures then at some point we might
gain control over this b5 square and
that's exactly what happened you do not
want to open up the position for example
if c captures on the five knight
captures on d5 this is just terrible i
mean that terrible terrible king is
coming to b1 rook to c1 check and there
is really no good square for this king
so instead after d5 alvarez decided to
keep the position closed pawn to c5 but
now magnus wins the b5 square and he
starts with queen to c4 now knight to b5
is coming so bishop to d6 putting
pressure on the bishop here and now
comes not knight to the b5 but knight to
e4 now attacking the the bishop twice
and also putting pressure on this c5
pawn so here we have king to b8 alireza
doesn't like the idea of bishop
characters knight captures and now how
do you how do you continue playing this
again the c5 pawn is hanging there's no
good way of defending it if you play b6
uh then just knight to e6 and you can
resign there's no no playing this
position it's absolutely disgusting so
after knight to e4 alireza played queen
a king to b8 and now magnus goes for
rook h to e1 uh you could also go for
the clean capture with knight captures
on f6 but maybe it's a bit too dangerous
as this is a rapid game uh you do win
some material knight captures on f6
queen to f5 now attacks the knight you
can trade bishops here captures or even
rook captures and go back with the
knight knight to the e4 chases away the
rook but now the rook can come to b6 and
it could get a little bit dangerous
white is still winning here
but magnus decides to go the other way
around he brings the last inactive piece
into the game the rook on h1 he plays
rook h to e1 bishop captures on it for
knight captures and now comes knight to
e5
knight to d6 might be a little bit more
precise uh but who's to say this is
rapid chess all it is is very long time
he plays knight to the e5 and now as the
queen is attacked queen to c3 so knight
captures is still happening so how can
all it is to stop this uh again there is
no good way if you play b6 to stop this
then again knight captures and f6 just
completely shatters um now it is this
position uh the knight here uh is
attacked and you don't have time to
react to this as your queen is also
hanging so you just lose all the
material so after queen c3 we have queen
to f5 now guarding the f6 pawn but now
pawn to g3 defending the knight on f4 we
have b6 as this was still hanging
already has to decide whether to give up
the c5 pawn or the f6 pawn he decides to
keep his king safe but now magnus just
plays knight captures on f6 we have
knight after d7 offering a trade of
knights and now uh magnus happily trades
knight captures knight captures to rook
to e7 uh rook h the e8 alireza also gets
his rook into the game and now rook did
the e1 threatening rook capture 78 so
here are the trades characters captures
magnus having some six and a half
minutes on the clock however has maybe
35 seconds maybe 40 seconds uh and now
we have knight to f6 trying to get the
knight into the game but magnus just
goes for the very clean queen to e5
check he no longer needs to attack he
was only using the attack to obtain a
winning advantage now the position is
objectively winning and he just goes for
the end game he's up upon his position
is more active and alireza does straight
queens but after magnus recaptures it
was also in this position unmoved the 33
that alireza furuja resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
it seems like yes you are only down one
pawn maybe you can play this the problem
is
uh after king to c7 let's say you try
something you want to activate your king
this is your last active move that you
will make in this game magnus just needs
to play something like king here king
here uh bring the king deeper into the
position and then just start capturing
like a knight captures here or something
because you can't really do anything
with black we're gonna play king to d2
now how do you continue playing this you
can't go uh in front of the
rook because if you go in front of the
rook then we are
just gonna play rookie six check and
pick up the knight so that's impossible
you can't try to get across as then the
rook no longer attacks the pawn so it's
just a free pawn on g6 so uh there's no
way to play this if you try knight d7
attack the rook we're just going to play
rook to e6 and now if knight to f8
trying to say okay maybe i can do some
uh damage here you're just going to play
rook to f6 and again there's still no
way to get across you're going to play
king e3 king here defend the pawn
capture here uh the entire king side
falls and then you just push the pawns
to victory so this is a very very
elementary uh to both of them of course
alireza knows this and i imagine he was
very much disgusted with his position so
he immediately uh resigned after rook
captures on e5
uh so yeah brilliant stuff by magnus he
bounces back uh
right into the match after losing that
weird game against alvarez
in the previous game and also uh for
some reason he was uh again smiling and
laughing for the entire game if any of
you have any insight as to why this is
so do share in the comments so yeah we
might all increase our vast knowledge uh
so uh once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank michael
cecchiaris hefla.com standish company
llc attila caja and brian enriquez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
ftx crypto cup until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day